where is the panchan Lama the second
most senior figure in Tibetan Buddhism
who was abducted by the Chinese
government on 17 May 1995 when he was
just six years old it's been 25 years
since he was taken into protective
custody as a Chinese put it he
reincarnates as a child somewhere on
Earth human rights organizations have
termed him the youngest political
prisoner in the world and traditionally
a key person in the process of finding
him is someone called The pensioned
Llama this is gerhan choki Naima at just
six years old gerhan was recognized as
The Reincarnation of the pension llama
the second highest wrecking figure in
Tibetan Buddhism which meant that this
six-year-old would become the successor
to the Dalai Lama once the Dalai Lama
was time to come which meant that one
day the six-year-old would have a lot of
influence and power all across Asia a
lot of influence and power that the
Chinese government was not a fan of so
just three days after he was recognized
as the pension llama the Chinese
government came enough and forcibly
disappeared the six-year-old this was in
1995. since then no one has ever heard
from him or seen him since the pension
llama was white off the face of the
Earth in a matter of a day the only
thing people have to go off of is this
mocha made by a forensic artist and
after 25 years of pressure the Chinese
government finally provided an answer to
the whereabouts of the pension llama
he's now a college graduate with a
stable job he quote received free
compulsory education when he was a child
passed the college entrance examination
and now has a job End quotes and that
quote neither the now 31 year old man or
his family wishes to be disturbed in
their current normal lives End quotes
but come on it's safe to say that the
kidnap pension llama is not roaming
around China operating a restaurant or
something where is the function llama
but the pension llama is not alone in
fact you don't need to be a high profile
figure to be disappeared by the Chinese
governments even your average regular
working-class citizen can vanish in a
heartbeats like Libo a Hong Kong
Bookshop owner who mysteriously vanished
one day in 2015. Leebo was known for
selling alternative uncensored books
that criticized the CCP and what's weird
is that four other booksellers who sell
the same stuff as Lee also disappeared
around the same time and when labo and
the other Publishers immersed just a few
months later they claimed that they were
not abducted by the CCP what no that's
Malarkey no we voluntarily chose to fall
off the face of the Earth ourselves
I have made it clear through the Hong
Kong police and my wife that I had
voluntarily come back to the mainland to
cooperate with the investigation it was
my personal act I have never been
kidnapped or been missed nor have I been
coerced or bribed so this is what's so
confusing here this manly Beau told the
interviewer that he illegally crossed
the border from Hong Kong to Mainland
China to participate in a Chinese police
investigation and in that interview he
also called on the Hong Kong police to
stop searching for him to stop the
missing person's case that had been
opened by his wife and he also strangely
renounced his British residency while
also trying to call on everybody to stop
searching for him or investigating his
case or maybe you're a school teacher
who's being a bit too radical with your
lesson plan or a homeowner who's
following a complaint because the
government illegally bowdoes her house
these people are just trying to live
their lives and survive
in October 2016
lamwinki a Bookseller in Hong Kong
disappeared in the south of China this
photo was taken in May 2015. two months
later he was arrested this is one of the
last Beautiful Moments we had together
one day they're here and the next poof
gone
hey song
take good care of to your my name is
sorry to bother everyone at this late my
son went missing on February 9th he has
been missing for nine days he hasn't
been home six days after I talked my
sister and my aunt both got abducted on
same day as a retaliation for my
activism so the big question is what
happens when you disappear in China
where do they take you hence you get
taken to one of China's secret black
sets stay dangerous and let's get into
it
foreign
[Music]
although I will never be able to travel
to China by the time you're watching
this I'll actually be taking my parents
on a trip back to Vietnam they're
finally retired and haven't been back in
decades I haven't been back since I was
a little kid so this is a really
meaningful trip for us that you guys
helped make possible we've really come
full circle from immigrating to America
dirt poor to where I'm at now so I
wanted to treat them with this trip and
I highly recommend you guys keep working
super hard so you too can support your
parents as well it is extremely
rewarding we'll also be traveling to
other Southeast Asian countries while
we're out there like Indonesia but the
problem is I don't know any Indonesian
but luckily that is where Babel comes in
Babel is one of the top language
learning apps in the entire world and
what I love about Babel is that they get
straight to teaching you practical stuff
that you would actually need to say in
real life and one of the languages they
offer is Indonesian pagi
foreign
[Music]
Babel's lessons are designed by real
language teachers and their methods are
so effective that Babel is
scientifically proven by academics from
places like Yale University to help you
start speaking a new language in just
three weeks with just a few minutes a
day over 10 million people have already
used Babel and they even offer a 20-day
money-back guarantee learning a new
language is also great for impressing
girls or a potential business client
wink wink so what are you waiting for
make 2023 the year you learn a new
language and get 60 off your Babel
subscription by clicking the link below
so pause the video and click the link
below right now for 60 off your Babel
subscription thanks to Babel for
sponsoring this video
foreign
[Music]
the year is 1982 and a new law in China
had just been passed it's called Sharon
and it allows police to arrest
suspicious looking people who don't have
an address registered within City Limits
so if you're found wandering city
streets without proof you've lived there
and you're deemed suspicious by the
police you could be detained this gave
police free range to arrest all the
homeless people and Beggars but you want
to know who else acts suspicious and
isn't registered in the city people who
travel from the country sought to file
complaints with the government these
disgusting leeches these people
technically don't live in the city and
they were walking around acting
suspicious filing complaints on things
like the government illegally seizing
their land their employer withholding
pay their house getting bulldoze out of
nowhere
people were speaking out against the CCP
making the government look bad by
exposing your wrongdoings and even
though this petitioning was being done
in a perfectly legal way you the
government really didn't like that and
thanks to Sharon police could arrest
anyone who even slightly brought the
ccp's order convenient right the problem
was with all these new arrests the
government had to put these undesirable
somewhere the existing prisons weren't
enough to house all of them so China
started building fancy new black sites
also known as black jails and they
started popping up everywhere by 2009
there were over 700 in operation all
apartment buildings nursing homes hotels
hostels they would all be suctioned off
and used as secret prisons
[Music]
one woman even reported that she was
jailed in a decorative shed in a public
park these jails were being filled with
activist lawyers journalists but mostly
petitioners who were innocently trying
to defend their basic human rights but
how did the police pull off all these
secret arrests without drawing too much
attention well it goes a little
something like this first they acquired
the target which could be an activist on
the street a petitioner standing in line
at their local office or whatever next
they sent in a thug dressed in normal
clothes pretending to be a journalist
the thug asked the target if they want
to be anonymously interviewed for their
Independent newspaper on how much they
hate the CCP the target says yes they
follow the thug to the interview
location and then
the target walks right into the Trap
[Music]
so what exactly goes on behind black
side bars well considering these jails
are completely outside the Chinese
Judicial System it's not very pretty
once the prisoner has been locked inside
they're immediately stripped of all
their belongings their phone wallet ID
cards are immediately taken and unlike
in a normal legal prison inmates are not
allowed to make a single phone call they
don't get access to a lawyer their
family won't know where they are or how
long they'll be gone they just have to
sit alone in the dark and hope that
they'll eventually get released most
black sites are hidden in apartment
buildings and hotels so the jail cell is
usually a single room sometimes there's
a bed sometimes there's nuts sometimes
guards will be in the room 24 7 watching
the prisoners while they sleep brush
their teeth and even while they go to
the bathroom
got this is a black jail the black side
guards make sure every moment of your
sentence is a living nightmare we're
talking horrific violence torture and
sexual abuse that would definitely get
this video to monetized if we talked
about it which is why you should click
that join button below to binge our
uncensored documentaries not available
anywhere else like our one on the cia's
black sides one prisoners that she was
handcuffed to the door and was forced to
stand there for three days straight
without food or water another 70 year
old woman who was detained in a black
jail for 115 days said there was just
enough food to not start to death and on
Wednesdays and Fridays she wasn't
allowed to eat or drink anything at all
and if food and sleep deprivation
doesn't do it they'll break you down
through physical torture some
ex-prisoners reported that they were
forced to sit on a dangling stool for 16
hours where their entire weight was
supported by just their lower back
others reported being beaten daily by
the prison guards one woman said that
she was shocked by cattle prods and was
immediately sent to a hospital because
she was so badly injured and why all
this violence and torture what is the
government's angle with all this well
after weeks and weeks of tour torture
the guards slide a contract in front of
them basically saying if you ever
petition protest or talk badly about the
CCP ever again we have full permission
to break your legs or kill you if they
don't sign the contract it's back to the
torture chamber and at this point the
prisoners are so hungry and sleep
deprived that they will do pretty much
anything to make the pain go away even
if it means sending away all their
rights and if you're someone famous with
a large audience they will literally
make you their personal puppet and have
you lie straight to the camera
[Music]
I violated Chinese law through my
activities here and I have cost harm for
the Chinese governments I have hurt the
feelings of the Chinese people
I have no complaints to make I've been
given good food plenty of sleep and I
have suffered no mistreatments of any
kind this is Peter dollar a Swedish
journalist who spent 23 days in a
Chinese black jail because of his work
on exposing the CCP on the morning of
January 4th 2016 Peter woke up to 20
policemen in his Apartments a black hood
was pulled over his face he was
literally black bagged and he was driven
to an undisclosed location for the next
23 days he sat in silence in an empty
room while two guards watched his every
move even while he sat on the toilets
Peter said he would constantly hear
people being beaten in the Next Room
over and during the nights a group of
guards would come in and scare him awake
some that he wasn't allowed to sleep at
all and then after not sleeping for
several days the guards would
interrogate him most interrogation
sessions would last four to six hours
often in the evening while you were a
little bit tired that we started after
weeks of this he eventually caved and
recorded a video statement saying that
he was the the one in the wrong that he
was the one that broke the law I
violated Chinese law through my
activities here and I have caused harm
to the Chinese governments I have hurt
the feelings of the Chinese people
I apologize sincerely for this and I'm
very sorry that this ever happened and
Peter is not the only foreign journalist
who has been disappeared like this if
you're Chinese you get treated much
worse than Peter Chang lay an Australian
Chinese reporter is currently being
detained in the black sites and a 9x9
foot cell that she has to share with
three other people I know there's only
one bed so they have to take turns
sleeping she says she had to stuff
sanitary path into her shoes because
they were so hard to walk in and that
she was pinned down in uncomfortable
chairs for really long periods with
heavy wooden boards and guess what after
two years she is still in there
the stuff that goes on behind the walls
of China's black sites is technically
against international law so how is the
CCP getting away with all of this why
isn't anyone stopping them
[Music]
the reason why these local Chinese
governments run these brutal black sites
is because as a government official if
the people from your state are
petitioning too much you get a decrease
in your pay ah yes these pesky citizens
complaining affects your bottom line we
can't have that now can we oh no no no
no but how are you going to stop your
people from complaining you could
provide resources to make their lives
better but that is difficult and
annoying so you put your foot down you
arrest them throw them in makeshift
jails and torture them until they stop
complaining think about it setting up
ghetto secret jails is way easier than
actually making their lives better you
approach local hotel hostile and nursing
home owners and paid them to house
prisoners for you between 22 and 29 per
prisoner per day you'll even pay
undercover thugs to lead your suspects
right to the front door and no one is
gonna say a word about it the CCP is on
your side the local police don't want to
get dark so they're on your side and
even though black sites are being
exposed in the media no one is swooping
in to save these people because what can
you do against the federal police so
basically you have your people trapped
and over the years you've expanded your
business to other countries you've
opened up a huge black side camp in
Dubai where you hold activists
petitioners and uyghurs where you've
tortured them until they've learned
their lesson and if journalists start
bringing up black sites with you just
deny it and keep things vague how does
the Chinese government justify the use
of so-called black jails
there are no black jails in China
anything being done not strictly
according to the law we're trying to
improve no one's going to fight back
anyways
foreign
is far from the only country that uses
black sets in fact the masters of
blacksides is actually America that's
because America's black sides are even
more terrifying and way more
sophisticated than China's whereas
China's black sites are located in China
and are used against Chinese citizens
America's block sets are located at
classified locations all over the world
and it's where the CIA sends high value
prisoners to get tortured far away from
U.S soil and far away from the watchful
eyes of the public and if you thought
China's black sites were brutal you have
seen nothing yet what happened in the
cia's black size was so brutal so
graphic that there is no way a public
video on it would be monetized that's
why we release a private documentary on
the cia's blackside program available
only to members of this Channel and you
can watch it right now by clicking the
join button below it's personally one of
my favorite private documentaries we've
done and this YouTube membership is
where we finally get to make all the
videos I wish we could make about how
the world works but never could like our
newest one on climate change and there's
a refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you joint you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for the first month after your first
month there is no refund scroll down and
click that join button now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]